May December your new film Todd Haynes
you and Julianne Moore you had never
worked with her no you seem like such a
perfect like fit I love her so much
thank you that's really nice because
I've admired her my like entire life and
I was so so excited to get to work with
her and especially with Todd who I also
worship it is the most compelling thank
you this movie I can't get over how good
it is it's very layered it's you're an
actress coming to play a woman and the
woman is Julianne Moore Natalie's the
actress she is a woman who had an affair
with a young boy and I mean young young
young young inappropriately young went
to prison had children with him they
have a fully realized family he is still
a kid himself and you're coming in to
play her life story like that's what you
learn in the first few minutes it's
incredible thank you what what what
surprised you about making this film I
think what surprised me was like how
smooth everything went um Todd we had 23
days to film the whole thing and that's
a sexy schedule very fast and usually
unpleasant um and it was so fun it was
Todd's just like amazing and Julianne's
amazing Charles Melton who plays this I
predict Academy Award he's he won the
Gotham award last night and he's so so
same with all of you guys in this film
it's it's just I I this is Oscars this
is what the Oscars are about's so hard
thank you that's so it's so
powerful I mean okay you've played a
ballerina you've played a first lady a
superhero in the MC Universe what have
you not played that you would love to
play
um I would love to do like a like a Kids
film like Mrs Doubtfire I love that
movie so are you Mrs Doubtfire in the
movie yes
[Music]
yes